هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي موجه في قلب العاصمه
السوريه نادرا ما تشن اسرائيل ضربات
مماثله داخل دمشق اذ تقتصر غارات
مقاتلاتها على مواقع عسكريه في اطراف
العاصمه السوريه وريفها ومناطق اخرى بعد
منتصف ليل السبت انطلقت صواريخ من جهه
الجولان السوري لتدك مواقع في قلب العاصمه
السوريه دمشق ومحيطها اصوات الانفجارات
ونيرانها علت في سماء العاصمه السوريه
قصفت الصواريخ الاسرائيليه بشكل رئيسي حيا
كفر سوسه جنوب غرب دمشق وهو احد الاحياء
الراقيه في العاصمه السوريه يضم حيكفر
سوسه مقر امنيه تشكل ما يسميه السوريون
بالمربع الامني وهي منطقه شديده المراقبه
من قبل قوات النظام وعاده ما تشهد انتشارا
عسكريا وامنيا واسعا يجاور المربع الامني
في كفر سوسه منشات ايرانيه
من بينها مدرسه ومركز ثقافي وفق ما اعلن
فان القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف مبان في محيط
المدرسه الايرانيه في المنطقه ما ادى
لتدمير مبنى وكانت هذه المنطقه قد شهدت
اغتيال عماد مغنيه القائد البارز السابق
في حزب الله اللبناني في 2008 بتفجير
سيارته وغير بعيد عن كفر سوسه طالت
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه منطقه اخرى تقع ما
بين السيده زينب التي تشهد وجودا ايرانيا
لافتا والديا بريف دمشق نجم عنها حرائق
وانفجارات وسبق ان تعرض موقع القصف
الاسرائيلي لعده تفجيرات كان ابرزها تفجير
سياره مفخخه في محيط المدرسه الايرانيه في
يوليو 2016 وتفجير اخر في يناير 2017 قيل
حينها ان الهدف غرفه عمليات واجتماعات
لقيادات تدير مجموعات عسكريه مدعومه من
ايران لم يتضح ما اذا كان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف بعينها فالى الان لم
يصدر اي تعليق رسمي عن اسرائيل التي تتحفظ
على الدوام عن تاكيد قيامها باي عمل عسكري
في سوريا وتكتفي فقط بالوعيد بانها ستكبح
محاولات ايران لترسيخ وجودها العسكري في
سوريا طهران نفت بشكل قاطع ان يكون اي من
مواطنيها قد قتل او اصيب في الغارات
الاسرائيليه على دمشق مؤكده ان جميع من
قتلوا في كفر سوسهم سوريون منذ ما يقرب من
عشره اعوام شان الجيش الاسرائيلي مئات
الضربات الجويه في سوريا تستهدف مواقع
للجيش السوري واهدافا ايرانيه واخرى لحزب
الله بينها مستودعات اسلحه وذخائر يقول
خبراء عسكريون اسرائيليون ان الغارات
الجويه جزء من تصعيد لصراع منخفض الحده
هدفه ابطاء الوجود العسكري المتنامي
لايران في سوريا